los ataques aquí en ucrania se centran
en la zona este en kharkiv donges esq y
lugar esa batalla por el control del
donbass que ahora mismo continúa activa
y donde han muerto civiles en las
últimas horas desde aquí desde nitro han
salido varios autobuses para intentar
evacuar a ciudadanos que huyen de los
bombardeos indiscriminados mientras en
el sur en la ciudad ocupada por el
ejército ruso dejar son las tropas o
craneanas aseguran que han tomado el
control de pueblos muy cercanos a esa
ciudad aquí en mi pro donde nos
encontramos es una región que hace
frontera con dos frentes abiertos con el
donbass al este y con sap orilla al sur
están sonando las sirenas no sé si
alcanzan a escucharlo pero esta región
está también bajo amenaza porque según
la inteligencia
ucraniana se esperan en las próximas
horas o días ataques a la ciudad donde
nació el presidente ucraniano selenski